well over time California has been a
leading indicator of what the rest of
the country becomes let's hope that's no
longer true California now has rampant
poverty failing schools drug needles and
human waste piling up on its sidewalks
bankrupt municipal governments of
vanishing middle-class at this point
California doesn't even have a shared
language almost half the state doesn't
speak English at home California be
saved or is it too late
Johncock doesn't think it's too late
he's a Republican running for governor
of California he got his nomination last
night he'll be facing Gavin Newsom in
November and he joins us mr. Cox thank
you for coming on
well Thank You Tucker thanks for having
me you grew up in California you didn't
live the California dream and now the
California Dream is the figure out ways
to get to Texas we got to change that
Gavin Newsom would run this state even
further into the ground so what would
you and it's sad it's sad even to report
on it but it matters it's the biggest
state and it's a bellwether state there
are so many problems in California we
could go on for the rest of the week on
this but if you were to narrow it down
to one thing you could change about the
state to keep the middle class from
fleeing to keep the state from going
bankrupt what would it be I have to say
it was the tax burden primarily the gas
tax has been really a problem here a
state senator Josh Newman was just
recalled yesterday by 60% they spent
eight million dollars of special
interest money to try to keep this guy
in office and the voters turned it out
and that's a that's that's a good sign
Tucker that that the voters here are
getting it you know this election is
going to provide a stark contrast Gavin
Newsom talked about it he he wants to
have a cradle to college nanny state
government as if this government isn't
big enough or taxing at us enough he
wants to expand that he's he wants to
double the income tax he wants to
increase property taxes and he wants to
make sure that we don't repeal this gas
tax I say the people of this state have
been taxed enough they're going to rebel
and
we're gonna leave that revolt here what
I mean California owes more to its
retired workers they could ever
conceivably repay I mean I don't think
you could ever repay that money it's too
much and now they're proposing to give
free Medicaid to illegal immigrants so
how would the state ever afford that or
any of this like what is the plan going
forward to keep that place solvent
well I'd like to think that we could
grow our way out of it but I don't even
think that's available to us so we're
gonna have to have some really stark
clear conversations with a lot of these
employee unions and we're you know as
usual it's the employees we're gonna
take the pipe on this they're the ones
that are gonna get hurt and I got to
tell you Tucker they haven't even begun
to put any money away for retiree health
care and there's all kinds of state
workers that are retiring at 53 54 years
old and they're they've been promised
health care until they qualify for
Medicare and as we know Medicare is
going broke at the federal level so you
know the big problem obviously is that
California can't print money and it's
credit rate is hanging by a thread I'm a
CPA that was my first degree and I tell
you what I've got a level with the
people of this state about the problems
with this unfunded debt I can't imagine
what it must be like to be a certified
public accountant in California to be a
math guy living in a state that doesn't
acknowledge the reality of math and must
be crazy John Cox thank you good luck
Godspeed I appreciate the opportunity
Thanks